joining us now the general manager of
the kansas city chiefs super bowl 54
champions super bowl 55 participants and
hoping once again to get back to the
super bowl for number 56 brett veach
brett welcome back how are you pal
mike great to be here doing good and um
like everyone else here excited about
scheduled release uh coming up soon this
week
what's the first thing you look at when
the chiefs games become available to you
well it's funny i mean you know in this
position
certainly every game is tough honestly
when i look at it i look at
for the when we have two home games
back-to-back because
that's when i know my mom and dad's
calling uh they like to come out here
for a week and they always like to
to marry it up to when the chiefs have
back-to-back home games so they get a
two-for-one right so
i'm always looking for that first
two-game home stand and expecting the
call for my mom and dad
now wait is it is this something that
you view as a positive
or is it negative no no reasonable minds
could differ
no no for sure it's a positive um you
know
as you get older you don't get to see
your parents as much so anytime they get
to come out here and visit the family
and hang out you always look forward to
that and
and again they want to they want to
maximize their opportunity here so them
maximizing their opportunities getting
a week here with two home games so uh
typically the first thing i do is i look
to see when we have that back-to-back
home
stand early in the season when the
weather's nice and and call the fam and
start working on travel for him
for them to get out here and i'm being
facetious i think that's a great thing
and family is more important than
anything else and i don't want there to
be any misunderstanding if your parents
happen to see this
and if they're as proud of you as they
should be they probably watch every
interview that you do that said
does part of you hope there isn't a
three-game
home stand well yeah because if you have
a three-game homestead then i guess
you're gonna have to have a three-game
road stand or play a bunch of road games
uh typically like to have those those
home games late in the season
uh we have a tremendous home field
advantage here and as the games become
more important and as the
the weather turns colder especially here
in missouri we certainly think that's a
great advantage for us
the chiefs were one of the teams that
was able to have a decent number of fans
throughout the course of the season
what's your understanding about what the
capacity will be
at arrowhead stadium this year i mean
look we're
obviously very optimistic and and like
to think the
the light at the end of the tunnel is
is there uh you know if you ask me i i
hope we have
a full capacity crowd there at arrowhead
stadium now again mark donovan and
uh we'll work with our staff upstairs
and work with the local government and
work with the league and
certainly safety is the most important
thing but
i'm an optimistic person and i'd like to
think we'd have full crowds this season
we're coming up on two weeks since the
2021 draft
for the first night you had no first
round pick that pick was traded
to the ravens for tackle orlando brown
what do you do
during the first round of a draft that
four hour marathon
and you don't have a pick how do you
keep yourself occupied
well yeah so the first 10 or 15 picks
are rather boring because
you know you don't have a pick and uh
you know you know
there's no moves to be made once you get
into the teens and 20 those
you start kind of doing you know your
number game so every team has
basically a percentage of players that
they need to be
uh they need available to have a chance
at a certain player so
uh once we get into the 20s we're really
starting to recalculate our second round
board and to see if we get the numbers
that we need to have
specific players that we like in that
zone for tomorrow and then
um so it starts off rather boring but
once you get into the 20s
um you know you start doing the
calculations in your mind and you get
with your staff and then as soon as the
last pick
is in for the day and then it's it's a
complete dismantling of the board and
you're just
restacking the board as if uh the friday
was the first day of the draft so
uh it starts off slow but like
everything else in this league
it picks up the intensity uh pretty
quick and
and then you're on to friday and and um
you know you're excited to for us and
for our situation to add two new players
i'm not looking for names but was there
any talk
any possibility any discussions about
possibly finding a way
into the bottom of round one for the
chiefs no
not not at all uh simply because we
exhausted those possibilities
um during you know the off season
and as we looked at options and what we
could do we went through that process
and then when orlando brown became
available
um you know we decided to go in that
direction uh you know certainly we
wanted to address the offense line in
the off season and we were able to add a
quality interior player in joe tooney
and we still were looking for
uh some tackle help and in particular
want to solidify that left tackle
position
certainly went through those exercises
in the weeks leading up to the draft and
what it would cost to move up and
what would be most advantageous for us
both in the short and long term
uh but then when the orlando brown trade
became available
that was the direction we decided to go
and once we made that move we were
certainly content on
you know working in volume and just
trying to focus on maximizing our picks
throughout the rest of the draft the
ravens are one of the chief's top
conference rivals quarterback lamar
jackson has called the chiefs
the ravens kryptonite when an
opportunity arises to trade for one of
the ravens starting offensive linemen
do you stop and think where's the catch
here why are they willing
to send one of their best offensive
linemen to a team that they are trying
so desperately to get past in the
postseason i mean i
i don't know if i'd necessarily do i
mean look that's a great organization
and eric does a great job there and and
you know ozzy before him they are always
winning games and winning
conference championships and division
championships and what have you so
um you know i think it's more
of a situation by situation i mean look
i think it was made early on that
orlando would like to play left tackle
and
you certainly knew of his family history
there baltimore and you also knew that
they respected him and then
i really get the sense it was they
wanted what was best for him and the
organization it was a unique scenario
and
and then mike you know you have the the
studer angle i mean left tackle i mean
there's a bunch of teams that have left
tackles there's a bunch of teams that
have high picks that want to allocate
those high picks and left tackles so
i think we were just in a in a really
good position in regards to
a specific need and a fit and they had a
player that they wanted to help out but
again i think you have to marry you know
what that player is looking for
with the team and their specific needs
again you'll have x amount of teams that
already have starting left tackles well
he wanted to play left tackle and then
you'll have some teams that could use a
left tackle but
they may be picking the top 10 top 15.
uh so then i think it kind of narrows
your suitors
so i think we just looked out with we
just had that specific need and they had
a
a specific player that was looking for
that position
and and i i've heard plenty of general
managers coaches and owners say in
recent years that when you give up that
first round pick for a player that
player becomes your de facto first round
pick
the difference though obviously is
contractual and we've seen this trend in
recent years whether it's laramie tunsil
whether it's jaylen ramsey jamal adams
guys get traded for one or more first
round picks
without a new contract on the way in
did you try to work out a new deal with
orlando brown as
as part of the trade or were you happy
to say we'll take this guy
and we'll worry about the contract later
well once baltimore allowed us to talk
to
um orlando and his agent and they you
know granted that
grant us that permission you know we had
lengthy conversations and you know one
of the things we talked about was
um still the unknown cap moving forward
and certainly
you know we all believe that a healthier
cap is is on the horizon and
um we still have some things that you
know we wanted to do and
and we just came to understanding that
uh
you know we're certainly going to be
committed to making this work long term
but both
parties would be happy to let it play
out and then you know work off a
structure next season we have a little
bit more clarification of
you know what the cap will be in in 22
and where we'll be moving forward i
think we'll have a lot more information
i think we'll all be able to do
something that you know helps both sides
you mentioned joe tooney a guy who was
franchise tagged last year by the
patriots obviously it would have been
very expensive for them to tag him again
a 20
raise over his tag number from last year
but they let him walk away they didn't
sign him to a long-term deal and they
had the cap space they had the cash
to do it is there any element when
you're dealing with a guy
who had played for the patriots that the
patriots are letting leave is there an
element of
of caution a buyer beware is there
something we're not missing here
why is it that the team that's had him
for five years doesn't want to keep him
did that creep into your thought process
at all when you evaluated joe tooney
no not at all i you know and you know
they are also a team that did franchise
them
uh the year before so um you know joe's
as
consistent and reliable as you get i
mean you know you talk about a player
that kind of checks all the boxes
smart tough durable position versatility
um you know a player that they coveted
enough last year to to franchise
certainly double franchise hikes
you know um are more expensive and um
they obviously had a lot of things that
they wanted to accomplish so sometimes
um you know the level of that double tag
uh gets in the way of all the things
they want to do
with in regards to you know dealing with
the overhaul of
of what they've done there so you know i
don't think that that ever crossed our
mind
we were just looking for um you know
our ability to upgrade that offensive
line in all areas and again you're
telling you're
talking about a guy with a long history
of of a
player in person coming back from his
time at north carolina state and the
information we had on him and just
look how he handled his career in such a
professional manner and played at such a
high level
um he's very much the model of
consistency and we're extremely excited
to add them to our roster
sammy watkins left for the ravens in
free agency that was a guy you kept
around for three years
what's your plan for replacing his
impact and production in the offense
yeah well sammy was a big part and you
know it's been said many times and he
was healthy i mean our offense was you
know unstoppable at times so
um it'll be tough to replace sami and
we're excited about
you know the players that we have on our
roster though i think you know we all
know how talented tyrique is and
we're all expecting a big step up in
nicole hartman byron pringle is a guy
that has
kept developing and getting better and
better year after year
demarcus robinson were able to retain
and he has a lot of familiarity in this
offense a lot of experience and we're
excited about our rookie
uh cornell powell uh you know he was a
guy that we felt
very fortunate to get there in the fifth
round we were able to had in him and a
pass receiving tight end and noah gray
so um those are two bigger bodies
obviously sammy was a bigger body helped
work the middle field with travis but
now being able to bring uh you know a
past receiving
tight end take some pressure off travis
and noah and then having a bigger body
receiver
that can really be a post type player
for us and cornell powell we're excited
to work both those guys in
and you know listen antonio callaway is
here too and and he's been having um
you know obviously just all virtual
meetings now but we like to think that
if we can get him up and running uh
he'll be out able to add another
um you know set of speed uh in that
group so we're excited we think we have
a lot of talent there's gonna be a lot
of competition at that position and
and uh inevitably if if we get pat time
uh those receivers will get open
when we had this conversation last year
you had used your first round pick on
running back
clyde edwards elaire we had some laughs
about that
sims and i both were flagging him to the
chiefs and you had noted that before the
draft and
he still was there when you picked him
now a year into his career
he had that big performance against the
texans to start the season
after that not the same kind of impact
what what would you say
you expect to see from him in the second
year of his career in the nfl
oh we certainly have high expectations
for clyde and and as you know like you
know he had that
that same game late in the season um
when i look back at the totality of our
season going 14-2
and and having a good run there and then
falling short
in the playoffs i i spoke with mickey a
few weeks ago and i really think that
same game was the turning point in our
season just because
it was such a physical game and we had a
bunch of guys get get banged up clyde
was one of them so
quite obviously had a great year but he
you know he missed a chunk of time there
right after that same game
um you know he had a groin and a high
ankle strain and
um you know listen one of those injuries
is hard enough to come back on he had he
had both of those he was still able to
get healthy for the playoffs and
contribute in both the buffalo game
and the tampa bay game but you know i
think clyde is an extremely special
player i think if he stays healthy with
the addition
of the lineman that we've added this
offseason you know we certainly expect
big things from clyde and in particular
i think you'll see him more in the
passing game and just you know
being able to utilize him in all
different ways and remember you know we
didn't even have an off season
last year with these rookies they had to
come in here um right out of college
zoom meeting zoom meeting zooming and
then boom they're out there day one at
training camp um
uh but credit to clyde i mean he was you
know one of those rookies that really
smart player
picked it up quick was able to was able
to start game one and
certainly had a impact right out of the
gate but um
again he stays healthy and stays on the
the track he's on
you know he'll be a he'll be a special
player for a long time
you mentioned injuries in the most
significant injury issue for the team
last year that turf toe suffered by
patrick mahomes plagued him in the
postseason
ultimately had surgery just three days
after super bowl 55.
how do you strike the balance as a as an
organization
between patrick mahomes using his
incredible ability
to escape pass rushers
regardless of straight line speed or
anything else he is able to escape those
guys but
if you run him too much you could have
wear and tear you could have
toe injuries foot injuries knee injuries
ankle injuries
how do you strike that balance as he
progresses deeper into his career
well that's i'll i'll leave that one in
the hands of coach reed
in our play callers it's funny though
mike you know a lot of these uh
teams you know are heavy rpo teams and
you know there are a lot of times where
uh you know pat's making his own call on
his own check
and and you know coach and i will joke
about all the time and uh
there's been countless numbers of games
and and carries by pat where coach and i
would joke after the game you know coach
would say you know i told pat to make
sure
you know he's given or he's you know
he's pitching he's not running the ball
but
you know it's one of those things it's
that fine line i mean he's such a
competitor
and you know you can give him all the
warnings but once he's on that field
he wants to go out there he wants to
dominate and he wants to put his team in
the best position possible and
unfortunately sometimes for us he'll
he'll throw his body around and
um but it's that constant communication
and you know living for the next down
and being smart and um you know you like
to think
as these players uh go on from year to
year they learn a little bit more and a
little bit more and
um you know certainly with pat we want
to exercise the utmost cautions with him
and
you know i think he understands that but
it's just something the coaches
uh work on a continual basis to try to
um control the emotions and
the competitiveness unfortunately with
patty's such a fierce competitor
supposed to do
five years ago dave gettleman was the
general manager of the panthers and i
asked him several times throughout the
off-season
have you watched super bowl 50 have you
watched super bowl 50 and i'm not sure
that he ever has or ever did
have you watched super bowl 55
i've watched it uh you know when we got
back certainly you watch it the next day
uh but like every super bowl highlights
and replays are
are played a lot um so
i find myself anytime there's a recap of
the game or any highlights quickly
turning
uh turn the channel and get into
something different because
it was a tough one to watch we had such
a great year and and it was such a crazy
year with
the pandemic and all the rules and
restrictions and our guys certainly
um overcame a lot of hurdles and you
know best
record in franchise history 14-2 um had
a really good performance against
buffalo in the ac championship game and
unfortunately this league is is you say
it every year it's a battle of attrition
and you know we were just some bodies
short and now that's taking nothing away
from tampa they played an unbelievable
game they were hot at the right time
they were healthy
you're hot and healthy in those playoffs
it's tough and a couple years ago we got
hot and healthy and and
you know we were able to finish the deal
and and this year we just
came a little bit short on the healthy
side of things and and hopefully
the work that we've done this offseason
the depth we build on on both the
offensive defense line will
help us survive a 17-game schedule
what was the number one thing though
that stood out to you when you watched
the game that that is relevant to your
job what do i need to do
to help us avoid an outcome like this
based upon what you saw in super bowl 55
what's that one thing that stood out
listen i think it just reinforces things
that you know we're already aware of and
it is just
a it's a battle of attrition i mean you
know
listen it we didn't have both starting
tackles and um we had an offensive guard
get hurt earlier in the season and we
had two players opt out so you know we
were
we were shorthanded to begin with but
the reality of it is every team
has the same scenarios they have to play
and and every year teams
lose players and it's our responsibility
in our job to make sure that
the roster is deep but on top of that
that your practice squad is always
uh deep and healthy and competitive
because it's interesting i mean you can
look at all these rosters day one and
and you know look at your starter
starting lineup week one
game one and then look at it week 16 or
17. it'll be completely different i mean
you'll have two or three guys that
came out of nowhere that are starting
you couldn't believe they're starting so
but it happens and you mentally prepare
yourself as you go into this
off season and you go into this training
camp you know look at your roster and
um two or three of these guys that you
have starting day one will not you know
unfortunately
will be on ir and and you know are you
deep enough
you know if can you handle two three
injuries as specific position and
you know where can you get better depth
and that's why there's really no off
season because
even during this stage of of the spring
we're
we're just trying to get the competitive
uh
you know balance of this 90 man as best
we can because we know it's only a
matter of time before
um your practice club players become
starters and your backups become
starters so it's really just
surviving the marathon that is the nfl
season
and from a glass half full standpoint
the thing that really
resonates with me from super bowl 55
there were a couple of efforts by
patrick mahomes
some of the best incompletions i've ever
seen in my life
willing the ball toward a receiver i
mean that level of determination drive
never
quit competitiveness and you throw in
the talent
you really do have something special
there
yeah and i mean listen i'm certainly
biased but you know he's the best player
in the nfl and
and you know that's uh you know
that's comforting to know that you got a
great head coach and you have
um you know a generational talent and
you know when i say he's the best
at every level his his competes is the
way he prepares
uh the way he leads um still humble
still hungry
and you know listen we're very fortunate
to have him now it was our job to go out
there make sure that he's
protected and continue to get him
weapons but um it's certainly
an exciting feeling for us for our
organization for our city to know that
um you know when the game's kicked off
on sunday that number 15 is our
quarterback
hey last thing for you and and i have to
say thank you for giving us
a nice little area of news
and developments and everything
associated that comes from that
revolutionary change to the numbering
system that the chiefs proposed
and and and i know the basic reason was
we ran out of numbers last year
but after the rule went through brett
tom brady started complaining about it i
don't know why i didn't complain about
it ahead of time maybe he didn't know
but what do you understand his concern
to be and do
do you think there's any merit to his
belief that it's a dumb
change to allow so many guys to wear
single digits and linebackers to wear
one all the way up to 49.
well i mean 59. yeah no i mean listen
there's certainly always varying
opinions especially when you make role
changes to things that have been in
place for for such a long time and
they're certainly
traditionalists and and listen i had a
long conversation with clark
uh before working with this we were just
in this unique
situation where we have a bunch of
retired numbers i think we have 12 or 13
members retired 10 of which are skilled
players
last year we had 16 players on the
practice squad we had the ability to
flex these players up and down
and we were just literally running out
of of numbers uh to give
defensive backs receivers and really it
was just a need for us we just needed
the ability with the expanded rosters
and expanded practice squads and flexing
people up and down just
more flexibility from numbers i think
the one we had three players wearing
number 30 out there in the practice
field and
i kind of said to our equipment manager
i said man we just we you know we have
to do this if college can do it why
can't we do it i mean college players
are wearing
numbers of different positions and um i
do think though that every team kind of
uh monitors the distribution of numbers
in a certain way and clark and i talked
about this i think
in general we'd like to keep the single
digits for quarterbacks and specialists
uh it could overflow into specific first
round picks or what have you
i don't think we're just going to start
handing out one to the first come first
server twos and threes but
i think it for us it was just a matter
of it's inevitable
it's going to come down sooner or later
rosters practice squads
have already gotten bigger rosters will
eventually get bigger and sooner or
later you're going to need the numbers
so let's just start working this in now
and getting used to this
numbering system like they do in college
and my understanding brett is it sailed
through
like four or five teams maybe were
against it is that right
yeah i think yeah i'm pretty sure that
the vote was overwhelmingly
in support of and you know i think the
the biggest detractors would probably be
just
some jersey sales on the marketing side
i mean a lot of these players
you know how it is might they have to
buy out those numbers so um some will
some won't and
i told clark and mark we won't have to
worry about that because
you know guys like pat and travis they
sell so many jerseys that it would
it wouldn't be a very good business
decision to change numbers because it
would cost them a ton of money
hey um do you know if the buccaneers
voted against the rule
i i don't know i i don't know
i'm gonna i don't believe so but i don't
i wouldn't quote me on that yeah again i
don't know why tom brady didn't say
anything before the vote
uh he made some arguments afterward and
they really haven't gotten much traction
but it was a fascinating
little wrinkle unexpected out of the
blue made for a robust offseason things
we can continue to talk about as these
new players get their new jerseys
brett we appreciate your time thanks
again for
uh sharing some of your knowledge and
experiences with us congratulations on
all your success we look forward to
talking to you again soon
always a pleasure mike thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports